[Brady:] Professor, I couldn't interview the famous Cédric Villani and not ask about the spider
[Prof. Villani:] Huh
[Brady:] Can I ask about the spider?
Anyone who's seen photos of you will see this spider...
...you wear it very often
Do you talk about where it comes from?
You have a few different ones, don't you?
Why do you wear a spider?
[Prof. Villani:] I've a lot of them but I never explain why
Let me, for Numberphile, show you some of my best specimens
[Brady:] Oh they even have special cases
[Prof. Villani:] Yeah I've to protect them
This is from Niger...
... was made by a Tuareg artist
This is a carnelian .. the stone
This I bought from a Bulgarian seller
This one comes from Uruguay
This one... that one... they were made for me
This one also was made for me
It's from Morocco ... it is Berber art
This one is from Eastern Europe... amber
Here are some sick ones that we have to take to operation
[Prof. Villani:] This one... [Brady:] That's your hospital, is it? [Prof. Villani:] It's a hospital
That one from Macedonia
That one from Argentina
They will go into... surgery
[Brady:] But the reason for the spider is ... this is an unanswered question
I'm not going to get an answer
This is the mystery of Cédric Villani
[Prof. Villani:] I think you will not get your answer
[Brady:] How many times are you asked about it?
[Prof. Villani:] About everyday
So... since I started wearing it ... ten years ago, it's been a lot of times...several thousand times
[Brady:] How many people know the answer?
[Prof. Villani:] Oh ... a..
...less than that
[More Villani on Numberphile:] See how much it folds and folds on itself.
[More Villani on Numberphile:] Also it remains in organic form, you know like ... some kind of salad
[Brady:] Alright but you know a thousand people are going to write comments under the video about what they think ... (laughs)